[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono molto onorata di considerare
l'impegno da sempre profuso nel
realizzare il futuro che avremmo voluto
vedere un esempio significativo per
questo tel
questa emergenza ha delineato un feroce
cambiamento che ha rivoluzionato e
trasformato ancora più velocemente la
vita di tutti anche la vita delle
persone che rappresenta un'azienda di
questo millennio che vive di innovazione
sono cresciuta pensando di vivere in una
dell'epoca e più entusiasmanti per
l'essere umano un'epoca vivace dinamica
un'epoca un con cui guardare in maniera
positiva il futuro le scoperte
scientifiche i diritti umani il primo
piede sulla luna internet un epoca in
qualche modo simile a quella che devono
aver vissuto nella fine del 1400 della
nostra penisola
l'inter e qualcuno scopriva l'america
leonardo da vinci dipingeva l'ultima
cena
michelangelo scolpito il david e senza
dimenticare che solo qualche decennio
prima gutenberg aveva dato oggi alla
stampa
penso spesso a questo parallelismo e
ritrovo molte similitudini internet come
la scoperta dell'america ha definito una
nuova geografia mettendo in dubbio
valori e competenze cambiamenti che
devono essere sembrati devastanti oggi
come allora con la scoperta dell'america
il mondo cambia forma e dimensione
qualcuno è dalla parte opposta si
ridefiniscono giorno dopo giorno i
confini esistono nuovi mondi nuovi modi
di relazionarsi nuove culture nuovi
prodotti
proprio come quello che è successo oggi
con internet
ma la cosa bella è che proprio mentre
con la scoperta dell'america si
definivano i limiti geografici nella
nostra penisola
i valori della cultura e le competenze
davano i natali a geni e modelli che a
ben guardare possiamo ritrovare anche
oggi alla fine del quattrocento moriva
il bellocchio grandissimo scultore e
pittore di fatto un vero talent scout un
leader coach per dirla lago leman quello
che crea la connessione tra la mission
aziendale la bottega i desideri e
bisogni degli
artisti nella sua bottega oggi l'avremmo
chiamata campus a firenze passarono
alcuni nomi tra i più conosciuti e
apprezzati della storia leonardo da
vinci il perugino botticelli ghirlandaio
verrocchio si circondava di giovani
talenti a cui non ordinava una
commissione da me invece loro la
possibilità di esprimere nelle
rispettive arti il loro stile le loro
percezioni dando così una prospettiva di
arte sempre nuova e rinnovata
permettendo una continua contaminazione
che portava originale scoperto e
stilistiche la formazione era una parte
fondamentale nella bottega venivano
selezionati i ragazzi abili nel disegno
e da lì cominciava il percorso verso una
maturazione di competenze abilità più
specializzate fino ad un raffinamento
nello stile e una grande profusione di
idee è data dal fatto che chi si
prendeva cura della formazione dei
giovani erano gli artisti e più esperti
che a loro volta erano stati addestrati
dai loro predecessori il sapere diffuso
così non svaniva dopo una generazione ma
anzi continuava e di volta in volta si
ampliava sempre più
proprio per questo la bottega del
verrocchio e che tanto successo perché
permise 1 svilupparsi di idee sempre
nuove e una capacità di mettere insieme
stili e personalità diverse un modello
innovativo che oggi chiameremmo
disruptive una grande sperimentazione
dovuta a formazione nei suoi dipendenti
che porta allo spiazzamento di tutti i
leader del mercato
nello stesso periodo troviamo un'altra
figura fondamentale in italia il
perugino allievo del verrocchio oltre ad
avere una capacità artistiche indiscusse
era un vero imprenditore un leader
esigente che mi piace associare all'idea
di bottega impresa e
all'internazionalizzazione il vasari
parla del verrocchio come di un uovo di
scarsa religione con la testa il suo
credo proiettati unicamente nelle sue
attività di artista di imprenditore ma
il perugino oltre avere capacità
artistiche evidenti
era un leader indiscusso
nell'organizzazione e nella gestione di
più bottega ripidi col suo modello di
bottega nelle principali città della
penisola e la sua fama di artista e uomo
di commercio
non anche spagna e in francia la sua
capacità al suo punto di forza stava nel
riuscire a prolungare i lavori dei
committenti in modo tale da avere sempre
un flusso di lavoro costante oggi
avremmo detto che garantiva il suo
ricorrente ma fu anche uno dei primi a
standardizzare i suoi prodotti in modo
tale che fosse più facile e più veloce e
seguirli e ciò lo portò a riuscire ad
accontentare un gran numero di
committenti che gli conferirono
prestigio e fama anche se questa sua
ripetitività di stile e canoni l'ho
portato negli ultimi anni ad essere
preferito ad artisti più innovativi
originali se infatti le usanze del tempo
tendevano a far crescere e prosperare le
proprie botteghe nei confini
territoriali di appartenenza al perugino
non si accontentò e riuscì a creare un
sistema efficace e dovuto a grandi
capacità logistiche e un impegno che lo
portarono ad essere uno dei più grandi
più voluti artisti e desiderati
dell'epoca la velocità di esecuzione era
garantita dal fatto che il pittore
riservava per sé le parti più complesse
del dipinto ma poi tutte le rifiniture
gli accorgimenti dell'opera erano
affidati a bari assistenti che erano
stati formati a perseguire lo stile del
maestro la sua organizzazione era
maniacale tanto che riusciva ad
accettare più richieste nello stesso
periodo e questo in porto un aumento
dell'uso della manodopera tanto fu
diversa la gestione della bottega
rispetto al suo mar maestro verrocchio
che prediligeva una commistione di stili
e forme una capacità di innovare sempre
nuova
mentre l'idea della bottega del perugino
era più pratica orientato all'efficienza
un modello di impresa che più si
avvicina ai giorni nostri dove possiamo
trovare una standardizzazione del
prodotto un efficienza e la velocità che
l'ho portata dei risultati mai sperati
infinite in terra straniera
a lui dobbiamo questo ulteriore
progresso che ha portato un cambiamento
nelle iniziative della bottega ha
confini non ancora esplorati un leader è
esigente
immaginiamo un perugino focalizzato
sull'obiettivo che esige perfezione e
rapidità dai propri collaboratori
uno che usa un modello di innovazione
molto strutturato e funzionale
perugino deve e vuole espandersi perciò
ha bisogno di portare i cambiamenti
piccoli ma costanti nel tempo in modo
tale che la sua impresa non subisca
oscillazioni previste oggi la chiameremo
forse innovazione incrementale l'impegno
nel miglioramento graduale di un
prodotto di successo è decisamente
inferiore rispetto a quello di
progettare un prodotto e servizio ex
novo per questo si procede aggiornando i
prodotti introducendo funzionalità
aggiuntive o migliorando alcuni
attributi in modo che il mercato possa
percepire una variazione di valore sono
gli allievi del perugino ce n'è un altro
un grandissimo che raffaello un talento
che sin da giovanissimo era richiesto da
molti signori nel centro italia
lui viaggio sin da giovanissimo ed ebbe
modo di conoscere molte influenze del
periodo fece un po come un moderno
erasmus e da questo ne trasse
ispirazione acclamato e desiderato da
tutti nelle diverse parti d'italia dopo
i successi si vide costretto ad aprire
una bottega ai tempi era la più grande
bottega di tutta roma si circondò di
abilissimi assistenti che riuscirono a
fare propri gli insegnamenti di raffaele
divennero grandi esponenti nella sua
maniera in moltissime città d'italia
i successi per le commissioni papa li
avevano portato una mole di lavoro così
consistente che raffaella aveva presto
imparato a delegare i suoi lavori a
giovani artisti
la delega contribuì notevolmente
all'innalzamento delle capacità degli
allievi che non si occupavano di parti
marginali della tela ma anzi delle parti
più centrali e sofisticate cosa che
riuscì molto accrescere le loro
competenze
tanto che non si distinguevano più le
parti svolte dal maestro e quelli dei
suoi allievi
un metodo che assolutamente non veniva
permesso nella bottega di michelangelo
il quale si incaricava personalmente di
sviluppare le sue opere lasciando agli
assistenti soltanto le parti marginali
la firma di raffaello era diventato
sinonimo di purezza ed eleganza ecco
perché la nobiltà romana faceva a gara
per avere un suo dipinto perché sapeva
esprimere alta classe e stile
il gusto capace di rimandare ai canoni
di una cultura d'avanguardia del tempo
un po come oggi la nascita dei brand
raffaello presente una capacità innata
nel piacere agli altri
disinvolto riesce a comunicare ai suoi
allievi la sua visione riuscendo ad
entrare nell'animo di ognuno
un leader visionario che con la
condivisione degli obiettivi e la
mission aziendale con i propri
collaboratori riesce a far si che si
crei una sorta di sogno condiviso
raffaello presenta un modo di innovare
dirompente infatti riesce a creare un
prodotto che non ha precedenti
cerca nel suo stile qualcosa di unico
difficile da ripetere
ecco perché la sua fama esploso
incontrastata e riesce a dare a quei
committenti qualcosa di nuovo che non
sapevano potesse esistere l'innovazione
radicale un po come quando apple
introdusse l'iphone
tutto questo per dire che che i valori
della cultura e le competenze sono
fondamentali in ogni epoca che la
combinazione dell'intelligenza delle
persone e delle organizzazioni giocano
un ruolo fondamentale nell'innovazione e
che lo scambio di idee e l'incontro con
l'altro hanno sempre portato nuove
prospettive e che anche se oggi sentiamo
sopraffatti dalla pandemia del covered
dal cambiamento climatico dobbiamo
essere fiduciosi nelle nostre capacità
perché anche in tempi recenti abbiamo
superato ostacoli insormontabili come
gli abomini del campo di concentramento
l'azzeramento di piombo nella benzina e
siamo sopravvissuti a chernobyl
nulla sarà più come prima ma il domani
potrebbe essere migliore se continueremo
ad avere il coraggio di essere curiosi
il coraggio di confrontarsi e di restare
unici e nella commissione di vere
grazie
[Applauso]